good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 17:15 object
class Euclid special containment
procedures foundation operated web
analysis BOTS gamma 84 anti-ben is to be
kept in constant operation and check for
defects twice a week by level 2 staff
member when functional the bots will
search a wide range of online message
boards for posts created by individuals
previously declared deceased if a
manifestation of SCP 17-15 on a website
is confirmed the bots will initiate a
distributed denial of service attack
against the site until foundation
personnel are able to either permanently
remove the site from operation or
convince the site's administrators that
SCP 17:15 is a person of malicious
intent a list of convincing cover
stories for the latter procedure can be
found in document 17 15 - 63 description
SCP 17 15 is an anomalous entity that
sporadically joins and integrates itself
into small online communities such as
message boards and wiki databases SCP
17-15 uses a different name on each
website adjoins however every recorded
user name chosen by the entity as either
included the word or been thematically
linked to all efforts to trace SCP 17-15
source have failed it is currently
unknown whether SCP 17-15 is a corporeal
entity accessing the Internet from a
physical location or an incorporeal
phenomenon that exists only on the
Internet itself
as CP 1715 describes itself differently
from manifestation to manifestation but
always claims to be between 15 and 30
years of age as CP 1715 typically
targets small but growing web
communities that are centered around
video games television programs musical
groups and similar interests SCP 1715
primarily targets english-speaking
communities although manifestation on
non-english web sites have also been
documented as CP 17 15 has proven
capable of manifesting on as many as
nine websites at once it is currently
unknown if this is the extent of its
limitations or merely the highest number
of cases observed by the foundation for
the most part as CP 1715 uses proper
grammar spelling punctuation and
spelling with only occasional errors and
displays a high level of knowledge
surrounding the topic of the website it
is participating in other members of the
online communities frequented by SCP
1715 generally consider it to be affable
polite enthusiastic and helpful because
of its attractive personality and active
level of participation as CP 1715 will
often become a highly respected user on
websites within a relatively short
amount of time on a number of occasions
the CP 17-15 is being promoted to
positions of authority by site
administrators as CP 1715 begins to show
anomalous properties once it has
established itself as a presence on an
online community usually within eight
weeks of its initial join date at that
time SCP 17:15 will send a number of
private messages to other site members
beginning with other popular users these
messages generally begin with a
declaration of friendship
followed by fabricated details regarding
SCP 17-15 s personal life and
with a request for the recipients
personal information if the user ignores
the message or responds without
providing any factual personal details
no anomalous effects will take place if
the user provides SCP 1715 with factual
personal information the user and their
account will become instances of
scp-1730 P 1715 s message instances of
scp-1730
such occurrences have included accidents
homicides and suicides
although these incidents usually result
in immediate death there have been cases
of SCP 1715 one instances being rendered
comatose brain-dead or similarly
incapacitated investigations performed
by local law enforcement units and
foundation agents have determined all
deaths to be apparently non-anomalous in
nature and explainable by forensic
evidence in one case foundation
investigators found evidence that an
individual had started planning his
murder several years before the SCP
17-15 one victim had ever joined the
message board it is currently unknown of
SCP 17:15 is somehow influencing these
events or if it actively seeks out
individuals it knows will die after an
instance of scp-1730
the corresponding instance of scp-1730 P
1715 once personality and writing style
instances of scp-1730 parts up until
their time of death but deny that they
are in fact
often accusing the inquiring party of
being a troll SCP 1715 - discussed the
same topics as their living counterparts
with the exception that they will
occasionally post messages that could be
interpreted as references to their
deceased state see addendum instances of
scp-1730 website once this takes place
all instances of scp-1730 beyond their
apparently symbiotic connection to SCP
1715 there does not appear to be a limit
to the amount of time SCP 1715 - can
remain active one group remained active
for eleven years analyzing and
discussing episodes of Buffy the Vampire
Slayer on a daily basis until the site
was eventually shut down by foundation
personnel addendum the following are
examples of posts by CP 1715 - that
could be interpreted as referencing
their deceased state as CP 1715 - 2 - 4
T 5 user tungsten real name Daniel age
16 cause of death fall or my balcony
context posted in a discussion thread
about allergies responding to a user who
complained of severe sinus headaches the
my head starts killing me as soon as
fall is over I can sympathize with that
sticking out tongue emoji I don't know
am I saying that right I'm not really
over
anyway SCP 1715 - 2 - 88 user Pavlov's
lemur real name Tyler age 22 cause of
death blood loss context users were
speculating the outcome of the series
finale of the television drama lost
after a user criticized one of Tyler's
theories a third user then came to
Tyler's defense no no it's cool I just
need to think outside the box except I
can't really do anything outside the box
kind of stuck actually except I'm not
sorry I started rambling again anyway
don't worry dude it was a bad idea I'm
not caught up about it or anything
except never mind forget it I'll be cool
with anything as long as Jack makes it
out okay somehow a CP 1715 - 2 - 109
user xxx lion tears xxx
real name Rebecca age 14 cause of death
decapitation context posted in a
discussion thread where users were
encouraged to post pictures of what
their faces look like don't really think
that's possible for me lol
communication log under the username
Carmichael Agent Meleager engaged SCP
17:15 in conversation on July 29th 2012
by an Internet Relay Chat application
SCP 1715 had recently became a moderator
on dotnet an online discussion board for
fans of the Final Fantasy video game
series and was serving as an operator
for the site's official chat room at the
time agent Malachor made contact because
this is a text log I'm gonna get someone
from the class to participate so Jimmy
why don't you help me okay in this case
I will be reading Stephen Foster the
pseudonym of the SCP 1715 instance Jimmy
will be playing
Carmichael Carmichael all right go ahead
hello
hey there need something ASL uh 18 male
Michigan what's your real name Brian
Parker why do you ask just curious
okay then because when we chatted back
on the maplestory board
you called youself Cameron Thomas ah
it's you guys again
you know cyber stalking is illegal right
why are you killing people war there I
haven't touched anybody I'm just a
lonely guy who likes to talk about Final
Fantasy and occasionally maplestory is
that so wrong
smiley face what are you doing to them
you mean my friends man didn't hurt them
or anything real life just kept getting
in the way for them they were always
saying they wish they could spend more
time online who are you really
dude stop it's against the site rules to
harass people for their personal
information of course I'm not going to
tell you who I really am after all you
could be anyone
sticking out tongue emoji Thank You
Jimmy I'll go back to your seat no
problem
following agent maligore's conversation
SCP 1715 created a forum post announcing
its departure from the website the
thread received 39 responses no fewer
than twenty six of which are believed to
have been written by deceased
individuals and that about does it today
thank you all for listening if indeed
you still are I'm looking at you Jimmy
and you were all dismissed goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Desmond Hoskins Andrey Bichette dr.
mortis Cody tench Pierce M Hamlin sy7
actual rebellion fidelia's untie verbal
if you would like a personalized thank
you at the end of each of my videos on
some other cool stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
volgen thank you
you